bitcoin is the king of cryptocurrency
since the creation of bitcoin we have
seen dozens of all coins hit the market
from cardono and ethereum to dogecoin
and of course
safe moon despite these introductions
though there has been little doubt that
bitcoin has always remained the leader
but when you consider the merits of
ethereum and the shortfalls of bitcoin
bitcoin's dominance isn't nearly as
clear over the long term
so here's why ethereum will squash
bitcoin in the long run
before we get into the merits of
ethereum let's first take a look at the
origins of ethereum
as this will tell us a lot about the
future potential of ethereum
ethereum was founded by vitalik buterin
and gavin wood in 2015.
vitalik had been in the crypto space
since his teenage years
and he had even co-founded bitcoin
magazine in 2012.
though he loved blockchain technology
and the potential of decentralized
finance
he had one major gripe with the bitcoin
he says that people in the bitcoin
community
weren't approaching a problem in the
right way according to vitalik
it seemed like the bitcoin community was
targeting individual applications
as opposed to blockchain technology as a
whole so
metallic would start pitching his vision
for a better cryptocurrency in 2013.
just a year later vitalik and gavin
would crowdfund
18 million dollars to develop ethereum
and we would see ethereum hit the market
in 2015.
fun fact vitalik was just 21 years old
when he launched ethereum
anyway a common misconception is that
ethereum is another cryptocurrency
just like bitcoin but this is actually
not true
ethereum is actually just a platform
technology
one cryptocurrency that's built on this
platform is ether
and ether is actually what people are
investing into when they say they bought
ethereum
as you can see ether was not developed
as a metoo coin
or as a quick cash grab no ether was
developed on the ethereum platform
which was meticulously designed to fix
the flaws of bitcoin
so it's not surprising to see that
ethereum is far stronger than bitcoin in
several aspects
such as utility bitcoin is often
described to be the digital gold
and that's a pretty accurate description
like gold
you don't really do much with bitcoin
some people argue that bitcoin can be
used for transactions
but no one buying bitcoin is really
looking to spend it at least not in the
short term
people investing into bitcoin are either
looking to make some quick cash in the
bore run
or is looking to hold for decades so
like gold
bitcoin is really just a store of value
albeit a rather volatile one
at this point ethereum on the other hand
has several use cases
such as smart contracts smart contracts
are basically just regular contracts
but the overseeing entity is just lines
of code right now we have plenty of
overseeing authorities that make sure
that all parties involved in a contract
are fairly treated
and that the terms of a contract are met
a great example
of a real-life contract is paying taxes
we pay taxes to the government
and the government ideally uses the
money to better our lives
in the meantime there are several
overseeing authorities that make sure
that everything is running smoothly
for instance if someone doesn't pay
their taxes they may be arrested by the
police
or raided by the fbi in extreme
situations
in this scenario the police and fbi are
the overseeing authorities
similarly if the government abuses their
power and spends money in wasteful ways
citizens have the right to sue the
government through the courts in which
case the courts
are the overseeing authority the problem
with this system
is that the overseeing authority is an
efficient and or biased
smart contracts aim to eliminate this
issue by making the ore facing
authorities
blockchain technology when a smart
contract is created
lines of code are written that describe
the various terms of the contract
the blockchain will automatically
enforce the terms of the contract and
ensure that all parties are fairly
served
going back to the tax example the
blockchain would keep track of all the
money you make in a year
and it will automatically calculate and
deduct the appropriate amount from your
crypto wallet at the end of the year
and transfer it to the irs as you can
see
this technology is extremely useful
within the financial industry
everything from taxes loans insurance
purchases securities trading and
basically anything that involves
transactions can benefit from smart
contracts
and right now ethereum is the primary
platform capable of the service
aside from smart contracts ethereum also
allows anyone to create programs on the
ethereum platform
these programs are called decentralized
applications and one of the most popular
decentralized applications
is nfts nfts are built on the ethereum
platform
and allow individuals to buy digital
files such as images videos
and audio now i'm not quite convinced
about the usefulness of nfts
and i know a lot of you guys aren't
either but that doesn't really matter
as nfts are just an example of a
decentralized application
a more practical application may be a
decentralized social media platform
social media giants like facebook google
and twitter not only have full control
over what is posted on their platforms
but they also have heaps of information
stored about all of us
this makes many of us uncomfortable for
obvious reasons
with a decently social media platform
not only would any one entity not be
able to censor certain information
but there also wouldn't be a corporate
giant tracking each and every one of our
posts
there's millions upon millions of use
cases for decentralized applications
and like with smart contracts ethereum
is the leader by far within this space
as well aside from being much more
useful than bitcoin
ethereum is also much more eco-friendly
i think you guys probably
already heard about elon's tweets that
suggest that bitcoin mining burns large
amounts of coal
and that bitcoin mining is therefore
environmentally unfriendly
people were quick to point out that 70
bitcoin mining is done using renewable
energy
but i don't think this is what elon musk
was really referring to
when he bashed on bitcoin mining i think
his main point was that bitcoin's energy
per transaction
is unfavorable which he points out at
the end of the tweet saying quote
we are also looking at other
cryptocurrencies that use less than one
percent of bitcoin's energy per
transaction
even if bitcoin was only mined with
renewable energy
the energy per transaction would still
be just as unfavorable as elon pointed
out
either however is far more efficient
when it comes to energy per transaction
because unlike bitcoin which uses a
proof of work model
ethereum is shifting to use a proof of
stake model
most of you guys are likely unfamiliar
with both of these models
so let's take a deeper look at each of
them bitcoin mining
as well as traditional ethereum mining
rely on the proof of work model
and i think the best way to explain this
model is through an example with iphones
let's say that you and a friend work at
an iphone repair shop
this repair shop specializes in
unlocking bricked iphones
all of the iphones at this shop have a
four-digit passcode and
unlimited attempts but neither of you
know what the passcode is
the owner of the shop however knows what
all the passcodes are
and he wants you guys to try all the
combinations and see if you arrive at
the same passcode as him
for every passcode you confirm with him
he promises to pay you 10
you're a pretty fast typer and you're
able to test out 100 passcodes
every single minute given that there are
10 000 total combinations
it takes you 5 000 attempts on average
to crack the passcode at 100 past quotes
per minute
you end up confirming a passcode once
every 50 minutes meaning that you earn
about 12 dollars per hour
your friend on the other hand is an
extremely fast typer
and he's able to test out 1000 passcodes
every minute
at that rate he's able to confirm a
passcode once every five minutes
earning himself 120 every single hour
in a proof of work model this is exactly
what miners are doing
but at a much larger scale whenever a
bitcoin transaction occurs
a unique 64-digit hexadecimal number is
created
miners are given the task of guessing
and confirming this number
and whoever verifies the transaction
first is rewarded some bitcoin
as you can see though this isn't
extremely inefficient process
when you're guessing iphone passcodes on
average you waste 4
999 tries on every single iphone
this means that 99.98 of your attempts
are a complete waste of time
energy and resources this inefficiency
gives bitcoin a very high energy
consumption per transaction
ethereum has also used this model for
basically their entire lifetime
but they're currently in the process of
switching to proof of stake
and they expect the transition to be
completed by the end of 2021
in a proof of stake model everything is
exactly the same
except for the brute force port going
back to the iphone example
the owner of the iphone shop recognizes
that having both of your brute force
passcode
is extremely inefficient as a result he
decides to tell you the passcode
and he just wants you to enter the
passcode and make sure that it really is
the right passcode
he tells either of you the passcode of
an iphone based on how much he can trust
both of you
his trust in you is based on how long
you have worked at the shop and how much
equity you own in the shop
let's say both of you have been working
at the shop for the same amount of time
but you only have one percent of the
shop while your friend owns 10
of the shop in this scenario the shop
owner trusts your friend
10 times more than you so he gives your
friends 10 times the number of phones to
verify
as it gives you if one of you guys lie
about a verification
or try to trick the shop owner in any
manner you'll lose a portion of your
stake in the business based on how
malicious reaction was
in terms of the ethereum universe the
trust you have is based on how much
ether you own
and how long you've owned your ether you
need to have a minimum of 30 to ether to
become a staker
and if you decide to become a mistaker
the network will give you transactions
to verify based on your credibility
if you don't fulfill your responsibility
of verifying these transactions
or you try to hack the network or
something you will lose portions or
all of your ether in a proof of stake
model you're not wasting any computing
power
so the energy per transaction is
oftentimes hundreds
if not thousands of times less than a
proof of work model
but wait a minute couldn't bitcoin just
shift to a proof of stake model too
well it definitely could and experts
predict that it will eventually happen
however a lot of the bitcoin community
is extremely reluctant to make the
switch
they claim that the proof of stake model
is less secure than the proof of work
model
but several all coins have been using
the proof of stake model for years at
this point
and there has been no evidence of less
security if anything
proof of stake is even more secure as
the people verifying transactions have a
strong incentive
to keep the given crypto strong as they
hold large amounts of it
moreover proof of work models have their
own security risks such as being 51
attacked i think the primary reason a
large part of the bitcoin community is
against the proof of stake model
is because they already invested large
amounts of money into mining equipment
and that computing power would basically
become useless if bitcoin transitions to
a proof of stake model
nonetheless the general consensus is
that bitcoin will eventually move to
proof of stake
and the proof of stake is the future
this means that ether
is the largest crypto supporting the
significantly more efficient
verification method
so ethereum not only offers more utility
but it has also proven to be much more
flexible and forward-looking
despite all of these advantages for me
bitcoin has always been the better
option for one reason
which is that bitcoin has a limited
supply while ether does not
likely one of the largest problems with
fiat currency is that governments keep
printing more of it
which continuously devalues the currency
and one of the main appeals of bitcoin
is that it has limited supply but as i
look deeper into this
my mind was changed here's the thing
though bitcoin has a limited supply
the last bitcoin isn't expected to be
mined till 2140
so bitcoin will be inflating for the
entirety of our lives
more importantly though ether will
actually have a lower inflation rate
than bitcoin
the bitcoin inflation rate is currently
1.76 percent per year
once ether completes a switch to proof
of stake though its inflation rate is
expected to be less than one percent
this isn't just an accident either since
the creation of ether
the developers have been keen to keep
the inflation rate of ether comparable
to bitcoin
if not less so despite having unlimited
supply
ether is actually just as deflationary
as bitcoin if not more
and that brings me on to my final point
which is that if bitcoin is digital gold
ethereum is digital oil every year
35 billion barrels of oil are consumed
right now
the cost per barrel of oil is about 60
and that's actually about the average
over the last 50 years
this means that roughly 2.1 trillion
dollars worth of oil is consumed
every year meanwhile the entire market
cap of gold
is only 11 trillion and that's not even
taking into account the industries that
oil makes possible such as the
automobile industry
the aviation industry the agriculture
industry the plastic industry
and countless more oil accounts for tens
of trillions of dollars of economic
output
every single year and i believe that
this is the raw ethereum will play in
the larger global economy
in terms of blockchain technology when
will ethereum actually take over bitcoin
then
well i don't think the price per ether
will ever surpass bitcoin
however i do believe that ether's market
cap will eventually surpass bitcoin's
market cap
right now ether's market cap is about 40
of that
of bitcoin but we are experiencing a
massive crash right now slash
potentially entering a bear market
at the peak of the last bowl cycle
ether's market cap peaked at 72 percent
of that of bitcoin
if we do have another pump this cycle
it's very possible that ether reaches 80
or 90
of bitcoin's market cap or it might even
barely surpass bitcoin's market cap
however i don't think ether will be able
to sustain the lead at this point in
time
during the next bear market ether will
likely end up flying far greater than
bitcoin in terms of percentage
once again in the 2025 bull market
though
there's a high probability in my opinion
that ether will at least momentarily
overtake bitcoin and by the 2030s i
think people will start to realize the
massive utilitarian potential
of ethereum and that ether will
sustainably overtake bitcoin
and become the new king of crypto again
this isn't to say that bitcoin will fail
but simply that ether will be even
bigger
than bitcoin if you're still not
convinced just take a look at history
the pioneer of an industry is almost
never the final victor
ford was the first to introduce mass
production cars but general motors ended
up being the bigger automobile company
aol and yahoo seemed to be the winners
of the internet in the 1990s
but we now know that that title goes to
google
ibm introduced the first smartphone in
the world in 1994
but now no one even knows they made a
smartphone
will bitcoin be any different comment
that down below
also drop a like if you learned
something new about ethereum
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari i'll see you
guys on the next one